eu transport ministers have agreed  informally on two initiatives to make  europe's air transport system more  efficient  and to develop the single european sky  scheme the scheme was launched in 2004.  it aims to improve competition in  europe's air transport sector  this is a sign of the willingness of all  participants  to take concrete and ambitious measures  to boost  aviation competitiveness the idea is to  overcome fragmentation of the common  airspace  and improve air traffic control as more  planes feel european skies  on rail transport the minister supported  a plan to repeal current regulation  on train operating companies which has  become obsolete  the aim is to harmonize eu legislation  cut red tape and ensure equal treatment  of companies  the council also agreed that upgrading  and investing  in the trans-european network would help  to boost eu economies